after Tuesday's midterms Tucker sat down
with former senator one of the great
guys in Washington Joe Lieberman hears
his conversation with independent Joe
senator thanks a lot for joining us
tonight
I'm delighted took her good to be back
thank you thank you
so as the results were coming in last
night and it was clear that the
Democrats are going to retake the House
of Representatives as predicted MSNBC
announced that one of the top priorities
of the incoming controlling party would
be to obtain Donald Trump's tax returns
do you think that's the mandate of this
election I don't whether they go for the
president's tax returns or not is up to
them but that certainly shouldn't be
their priority I want to give you my
personal perspective on left side I'm
the chairman of a group called No Labels
we've been working and encouraged
bipartisanship in Congress and this year
for the first time we actually got into
campaigns of people who were part of
what we call the problem solvers caucus
we raised over 15 million dollars we
supported 28 candidates 14 Republicans
14 Democrats and members of the problem
solvers Cluckers 23 of them won and the
Democrats who won which i think is why
the democrats now control the house were
actually more moderate independent
minded problem solvers so I don't think
they're they're going to go to Congress
to get president Trump's tax returns I
think they're gonna go to try to get
something done for their constituents
and their country so and I think all of
us hope that that's that that happens
but it does raise the question who's in
charge of the Democratic Party so is
that [ __ ] is bigger than the Alexandra
Cascio cortes caucus I don't know how
many I don't think there are many people
who are exactly where cuz your
congresswoman elect as your Cortes is
really a self-proclaimed socialist I
think weak on foreign policy and defense
policy basically wants the government to
take over a lot of the economy but
what worried me when she was elected
Tucker was that a lot of people
including some potential Democratic
presidential candidates began to run
after some of the positions she was
taking including calling for the
abolition now of ice the Immigration and
Customs Enforcement Agency yes that's
ridiculous how can it you may disagree
with its policies but how can you have a
country where there's no group enforcing
immigration and customs laws so I think
this is yes what happened yesterday is
was was good for Democrats in the house
but it's also a warning
I think they regained the majority by
running more moderate candidates in
suburbs and moderate Democrats actually
lost in the Senate and that showed I
think some strength in President Trump
who worked hard to defeat a lot of those
moderate Democrats so there's there's
good news and bad news and warnings for
both parties here and the last thing the
Democratic parties should do if it wants
to have a chance to win the presidential
election in 2020 is to follow after
congresswoman elect Ocasio Cortes
there's just not many people who believe
that in America thank God I don't know
how many Democratic strategist watch
this show I hope all of them and I hope
they write down your advice senators
great to see you tonight thanks Arthur
good to be with you thanks